[Musique]
le Sénégal fait partie de je pense que
c'est vrai pour toute pour toute
l'Afrique ça fait partie de ces pays où
tu poses ta caméra et
immédiatement il se passe quelque chose
les couleurs elles sont elles sont
extraordinaires
[Musique]
pourquoi je me lave les glaces
vous savez c'est de la faute de
Minecraft et les démons de la pâte il
faut que je fasse et je trouve que le
Sénégal a un gros potentiel
cinématographique que ce soit au niveau
des acteurs au niveau des productions au
niveau du matériel je sais qu'on a un
potentiel et qu'on peut aller loin après
ce qui est dommage c'est qu'on s'arrête
au séries alors qu'en ce moment il faut
vraiment qu'on essaie de miser sur les
films
allez c'est coupé merci
nous au début quand on a commencé
c'était vraiment une production tous les
deux ans ou trois ans
chaque année on est on a presque deux
trois quatre projets de mon métrage au
Sénégal et peut-être même pas plus donc
là ça a vraiment changé c'est cinq
dernières années
[Musique]
je pense qu'on a le garage
si quelques temps ça ira en groupe plus
loin parce que tout le monde commence à
se centrer un peu à se retourner vers
l'Afrique et plus particulièrement le
Sénégal et la Côte d'Ivoire mais voilà
je pense que il y a il y a beaucoup
d'opportunités qui viendront et qu'il y
aura à faire